people literally can't help themselves
but to look at their phone while they're
waiting in line and it's like 90 plus
percent of people they can't they can't
stop themselves and uh oh it's never
really been a big fan of this whole
phone culture and what it's turned into
in terms of hanging out with people
everybody's on their phones all the time
and I just want to hear your thoughts on
it well yeah I mean look A buddy of mine
just said he got text neck and text neck
is uh some tightening of the muscles and
some vertebrae issues you can get from
the constant being down looking down
I think that it definitely makes us
Dumber over time
because we're not our our heads aren't
up here we're not as alert and aware so
our awareness is in time could be
affected
I was sitting at a table or something
the other day and some girl said that
kids are being born with like
indentations in their fingers from where
their parents like always holding
holding their cell phone you know like
their pinky finger has like an indent on
it from where it the cell phone rests on
it and I thought that that girl was out
of her [__] mind but it did make me
start to think how many things could be
genetic like how many you know based on
us being addicted to our phones and I'm
going to say addicted because
uh the one thing that I have withdrawals
from is my phone if I can't find my
phone
I get you can feel it in your body when
you can't find it and that's withdrawals
that's not like oh I just can't find my
phone that's a real thing
you know when you can't leave home
without it when you can't go like that's
addiction
and it's interesting how it's okay to be
addicted to our phone but it's not okay
to be a you know like addiction is
usually bad
but with our phones it's it's like we
accept it like it's okay like it's a
means to
it like it's a means to something so
it's a good question I worry about it
too and I don't know what the answers
are I don't know if at some point do we
start to
you know lose like our per feeling of
like peripheral awareness because we're
so right here looking at a screen that
would make sense to me because if our
old screen was
our eyes looking out you know just the
world in front of us and our new screen
is just this little world in our hands
then you would think that our ability to
interpret and awareness would would
manifest or would adjust to adapt to
this new screen over time so yeah I'm
curious but how long does that kind of
stuff take you know for a human to
genetically
adjust like through like generation and
generation I have no idea but it makes
me scared for sure
you know meeting people is old-fashioned
you know if you um I mean look we go to
the fist bump now
um I thought about this the other day
like I always used to scrapbook bro I'll
be real about that [__] you know
I mean I was the only dude you knew
probably in you know when I was a
freshman in college I was doing steroids
and scrapbooking you know what I'm
saying man I was out in both games
and and if I tell people oh I used to
scrapbook
people like look at this my hug you know
look at this why is that you know look
at this boy coming a little bit lavender
he coming in a little bit lavender
but the truth is Cat Daddy okay you're
on Instagram now aren't you well all of
a sudden you everybody a scrapbooker
because that's all Instagram is a
scrapbooking
how many everybody's a scrapbooker now
so maybe I was a progressive if I think
about it like that maybe I was early to
the game
but it's very scary man it's very scary
to think what's gonna happen
you know because I know that I'm
addicted
you know I deal with addiction in other
parts of my life or you know have have
chosen to look at that
and I'm but I noticed it with my phone I
notice it that's a real thing
how do we beat it do we beat it there's
no going back
you know where it's like we're not going
to go back to a time where we don't use
our phones I don't think
you know I don't think at all now do we
start to monitor it if there become
Health serious health risks
then that could be something that
happens I mean we're really in an
experimental time because we've never
had
you know we're kind of the first
generation you know at my age I'm kind
of the first generation where you know I
started using a phone a cell phone when
I was 20.
you know we're going to find out what
the long-term effects are so who knows
what if our legs fall off in a couple of
months you know this huge class action
lawsuit against a t
you know can you imagine even just all
the wheelchairs trying to show up at the
courthouse
[__] could get wild
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one